Okay Michael, I didn't give you as much time as I normally
do because you think you already know the answer. So what's the answer?
>> So, you know, I'd rather get the
plus 2's occasionally, so I'll say the bottom one.
>> No.
>> Wait, what? You're not going to tell me the top one's better?
>> no, it's not.
>> Okay then that feels like a trick question.
>> It's not a trick question. The answer
is, neither one is better than the other.
>> Oh, so I had to give neither?
>> Or both.
>> Which is better, and I can click
on neither.
>> Or you could click on both. Okay. So you thought
that the bottom one was better, what was your reasoning for that?
>> Because, sort of moment to moment, sometimes
I'm getting plus one's, and that matches what I
would've gotten if I had been on the other
bank. But then sometimes I get plus two's, which
is actually better than what I would have gotten
on the other bank. And so, I'm, I'm, I
never feel any regret being on the bottom bank.
I only feel regret being on the top bank.
>> That's fine. So, what would you say
the utility of the sequence along the bottom actually is?
>> 1 plus 1 plus 2 plus 1 plus 1 plus 2 plus dot, dot, dot.
>> Which is equal to?
>> infinity, I guess.
>> That's right. What about the utility of the top one?
>> 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus, that's also infinity.
>> Yep. So the utility of both of those sequences is equal
to infinity. Do you think one of them is bigger than the other?
>> You drew the bottom one a larg, a little bit larger.
>> I did.
Or longer, anyway.
>> Yeah.
>> But, in the end, the sum of the rewards that you get are both
going to be infinity. So the truth is, neither
one of them is better than the other.
>> I still don't think you can say that both are better.
>> You can't get around that.
>> But yeah, I see, I see, neither, I can see neither is better.
>> Or that both are better. Neither is better, both is
better, whatever. The point is that, they're both equal to infinity.
>> Hm.
>> And the reason they're
equal to infinity is because all we're doing is accumulating
rewards. And, if we're always going to be able to get positive
rewards no matter what we do, then it doesn't matter
what we do. This is the existential dilemma of being immortal.
>> Oh, living forever.
>> Right.
>> So if you live forever then, like why should you care about anything ever?
>> Right I mean, everyone, every all the mortal people are going to die and
one day they'll all be, you know, an infinite
amount of time in your past. I could do
this thing here, which is pleasurable, or I could
do this thing right now, that, you know, will, is
less pleasurable, but will eventually get me to a
better place. But if I'm going to live forever, and I
can always get to a better place, than it
really doesn't matter what I do. It really doesn't matter.
>> Mm.
>> Because I'm just accumulating rewards,
I'm living forever, and I'm going to,
infinity is infinity and there's no really no way to compare them.
Having said that, your original notion that, look, it feels like I
should never regret having taken the second path compared to the first
because I will occasionally do better. Seems like the right intuition to have.
>> I see but it's just not built into this particular utility scheme.
>> Right, but it turns out there's a very easy way we can build
it into this utility scheme by just making one tiny little change. Would you
like to see it?
>> Yes.
>> Beautiful, let's see it then